hi I'm Erik Bosse and stranger things
season 2 has a new final trailer with
lots of subtle eighties references and
conspiracy theory level details that
only a crazed shut-in like me would ever
really care about I'm gonna run through
this frame by frame and point out all
the interesting stuff you might have
missed cool let's get started
[Music]
this trailer opens with that box in the
woods at chief hopper left food in for
11 defined at the end of last season
notice that the a goes and container of
cookies are the same exact ones that he
left for her in that scene this is
probably the same night so this gives us
an idea of this season's timeline even
though most of these the two will
probably take place 10 months after
season 1 in October 1984 I think we'll
see some scenes from the interim period
in between also notice the clothes at 11
is wearing that hat and coat looked
pretty big for her they probably belong
to hopper as well now at the end of last
season at first I thought this box could
be something at 11 could access from
either side of this dimensional divided
like that vanishing cabinet Harry Potter
but last trailer ended with what looked
like 11 finding another rift from the
upside down back into our dimension so
it looks like she is back let's move on
[Music]
maybe all this is happening for a reason
okay here we see some shots from last
trailer of the wheeler house on
Halloween with that Bush 84 sign and
then this new amazing shot of will
buyers in an upside down version of this
street looking up at the new monster of
this season in the past I've speculated
that this could be the Thistle Hydra the
DND monster teased at the end of last
season
those long tentacles definitely look
like they could belong to it that's why
Hydra but I go into some ultimate
theories for inspirations in our past
trailer breakdown so check those out
then we see Nancy and Jonathan being led
into this room with a bunch of classic
conspiracy theory clippings on the walls
yes red yarn and thumbtacks a must for
any true nutcase but you know actually
this is stranger things a world where
the crazies are vindicated also this guy
is a journalist looking into Barb's
disappearance so I feel pretty bad for
calling him in that case if you look
closely at the wall you can barely make
her out in a couple of these newspaper
photos and then notice that timeline on
the left there pick up Nancy wheeler
parking Lee car Harrington house
remember this is Barb's timeline on the
night she disappeared she gave Nancy a
ride and she was all like you Nancy
let's just practice clarinet discuss
which member the baby-sitters club is
most responsible and then band gone
there's also a police sketch of eleven
over on the far right so this journalist
knows the girl is somehow connected to
this mystery I'm just glad season two
hasn't left Barb's disappearance as a
loose end and actually intends to follow
up on it and I know season 1 clearly
showed Barb's body and the upside down
but here's a totally plausible theory
for you what if this vessel Hydra
Monster is barb we know the demagogue
and cocooned her and will orally
implanted some weird vine inside of them
which left will copying up some slugs in
the final scene of season one maybe if
left undisturbed with that implant
inside her it could have transformed
bard
into a huge tentacled monster I'm just
saying guys streets or things have
happened actually on stranger things
this would have been the strangest thing
to have happened anyway let's move on
these are not like this is happening
it all leads back to here
okay in this section there's this
overhead shot following the car and
considering everything in the show is
probably an 80s referenced I feel like
this could be an O Maj to the opening
shots of the shining which remember
followed the Torrance family as they
drove to the Overlook Hotel there's just
something very creepy and ominous about
following a car from a high over it
angle then we see Mike and will after
Will's had a rough night's sleep he
notice those night sweats on his
sweatshirt there and looking at the
background will has clearly been bit by
the drawing bug what is it everyone on
the show wallpaper their homes with
paranoid clippings but notice this
drawing over here on the far right that
to me looks like Gandalf the gray we do
know from last season that the kids are
into Lord of the Rings because of course
they are remember we also saw will draw
a different Wizard and one of the
flashbacks remember the wizard was also
wills role in the opening D&D game and
like Gandalf he seemed to die but then
miraculously came back yeah I know I'm
mixing wizard references I mean he was
the Boy Who Lived
let's move on
[Music]
and what have you done nothing
[Music]
this section gives us this shot of the
kids in the upside down and I love the
lighting in the shot the beams of light
from these flashlights definitely have a
Spielberg E in quality as we saw in
movies like ET Spielberg loves hiding
characters faces behind beams of light
we also see Joyce here in hospital
scrubs which is a little odd because
it's season 1 she worked at a general
store so maybe she just had to wear
these scrubs while wil was being
operated on we also see Paul Reiser's
scientist character riser is another
great 80s nostalgia cameo along with
Sean Astin Reiser played Burke in the
movie aliens which is one of these
sci-fi classics reference all throughout
season 1 Burke was an [ __ ]
representative from the Weyland
corporation who got people killed to
acquire dangerous specimens for his
company while looking out for his own
ass so all I could see Reiser playing a
similar character here let's move on
[Music]
I think my favorite shot of this trailer
is this one of eleven as she
telekinetically undoes the chain lock
it's kind of a play on that classic
supernatural force trying to break into
the house trope as the dead bolts
impossibly unlock themselves but look
closely the design of this house the
blue paint on the porch rafters the
pattern on the window curtain the white
wood panel hallway yes this is where
Terry Ives lives Elevens mother remember
Joyce and hopper visited this same house
in episode six looking for more
information on 11 in Hawkins lab so it
looks like 11 has come home and guys she
looks pissed okay let's move on
[Music]
[Music]
so in this section we get some more
shots of wills drawings and our last
breakdown I speculated that these
drawings could form a map of a tunnel to
the upside down
and once again this season it looks like
Joyce buyers will have to use her living
room to assemble a way to communicate
with her son and this next shot of
destiny Steve looks like it could be
them looking into these tunnels actually
this angle reminds me a lot of another
famous Stephen King adaptation the
Shawshank Redemption when the warden
pulled back the Rita Hayworth poster in
the camera creeps backward from the
prison cell deep into the unknown and I
got to talk about the music of this
trailer this track is called
last ray of light composed for this
trailer by alexander dmitriyevich
this guy's composed and credited trailer
music for a ton of movies here he fuses
this intense organ with be classic synth
tones from the season one score which
strongly evokes Hans Zimmer's score from
interstellar
or maybe I'm just thinking this scene
because all of the rotating camera shots
in this trailer okay let's move on do
you think it's weird I really seem to
hang out when the world's about to end
[Applause]
it's not like it was before it's grown
it's Judgment Day
okay one of the most mysterious shots in
this trailer shows Paul Reiser's
character and other scientists freaking
out at this experiment with a line of
separate flasks containing some strange
fluid that each swirl like a whirlpool
now let's look at the shot more closely
scientists are using a Bunsen burner to
heat one Erlenmeyer flask containing the
substance yes I remember some of the
words from high school chemistry that
causes a physical reaction with the
fluid swirling but then each of the
separate flasks despite not being heated
are also reacting as if they were
interesting this seems very similar to
the experiment in John Carpenter's The
Thing something that I brought up as a
reference in the past with stranger
things Kurt Russell's character McCready
separates blood samples taken from each
of the suspects and heats each sample
knowing these shapeshifter alien hates
fire and any one part of this organisms
DNA will elicit a reaction from the
source so I'm thinking in this case
whatever this substance is each of these
samples may belong to the same
supernatural organism so that they share
this metaphysical connection I actually
have more on this theory later we also
see separate shots of Joyce and Steve
hacking away at something this upward
shot of Joyce looks a lot like that shot
of hopper from the past trailer now in
my past breakdown things I speculated
that season 2 might feature an
infestation of small and two-dimensional
creatures may be ones that spawn from
the slug that will cocked up um maybe
this is the thing that Dustin traps in
his Ghostbuster trap the same things
that are perhaps ruining all of Hopkins
pumpkins we also get this great shot of
Steve tying a bandana around his head
yes this is a reference to the Karate
Kid
another 1984 classic and yeah there's a
little ironic since Steve's character
initially in season 1 was kind of
inspired by the classic 80s bully trope
like Johnny and the Karate Kid but if
you think about it Johnny did like
Steven up redeeming himself and before I
move on there are some shots of the kids
in a bus or an RV with these mysterious
thumps on the roof now this reminded me
a lot of the scene from another a
nostalgic Spielberg II movie super 8 the
one where the alien attacked the kids on
the bus okay let's move on to the next
section
doesn't much help as we can get
[Music]
anymore
okay in this section we see that the
boys have recruited max to their group
she's the newcomer of the season - it
actually is probably also the source of
the title of episode 1 Mad Max there's
also this shot of hopper getting hosed
down and decontaminated now as I
mentioned before with that opening shot
of 11:00 I think the timeline of season
2 might include some scenes right after
the events of season 1 which remember
ended with hopper going along with some
government agents so I think we're gonna
see some of this harsh quarantine Ian
and debriefing as the government tries
to silence ha poor after what he
witnessed in Hawkins lab moving along to
this next shot I love the scale of this
with tiny tiny tiny will buyers in the
bottom left in the giant tentacled
monster seemingly reaching out to him
now look closely at the texture of this
tentacle on the right side of the frame
if you look closely as it moves it looks
like it could be a little fluid like
it's made of some kind of gas this
connects back to two other shots from
this trailer first the shot of the
monster pushing through the fog earlier
on I don't think that's fog I think
that's the amorphous texture of this
creatures skin and then there was that
shot of a scientist I think the fluid
that they were hitting was taken from
this creature that's why all the samples
react the same they're part of an
organism ok this bully looking guy is
Billy stepbrother of Max played by dr.
Montgomery and if he paused just the
right frame it looks like these punching
Jonathon there can pinpoint the second
his jaw gets bruised yeah this guy can't
catch a break maybe Billy is holding
against Jonathan that his brother will
got his stepsister in this whole mess or
maybe he's just an [ __ ] huh Murray
actually said he was told to watch Jack
Nicholson in the shining for inspiration
for this character so I expect we'll see
some sudden violent outbursts from him
like this give me the bat Steve then we
get another one of these POV shots
rushing towards some terrified
scientists inside an elevator feel like
this is a callback to the opening shot
of the very first season then we get
these punks and Halloween masks which at
first seems like a nod to the purge but
it also feels like another Karate Kid
reference like these jerks feel like
they could be part of the Cobra Kai dojo
with their skeleton costumes and before
I move on we get another shot of Lucas
using his slingshot we saw him do this
against the demagogue and in season one
and it's a reference to Stephen King's
it in the book and in the 90s adaptation
Beverly uses a slingshot a chunk of
silver to attack Pennywise let's move on
you should
now it's almost here
okay so there are a lot of quick shots
of terrified characters here but I just
want to single out one that's broken up
shot of 11 as it looks like she tries to
use her telekinesis to move a massive
train car it's interesting here how she
collapses to her knees and defeat but
she seems so vulnerable last season she
was able to flip that government van
without too much effort then again a van
is about 5,000 pounds so on a heavy day
where as a freight train car it can be
upwards around 300 thousand pounds so
you know I'll you shouldn't feel too bad
about this maybe try a telekinesis in
with your knees
either way I'm wondering if Elevens
powers are gonna start fading in season
2 as she becomes less of a supernatural
freak experiment and more of a normal
young girl be interesting to see if she
actually starts missing her powers let
me know what you think in the comments
but let's move on to the final section
boom with the nails great to be honest I
don't really remember Steve's bat being
a particularly iconic moment from season
1 but I do like the fact that Dustin and
Steve are gonna start spending more time
together I can't think of any two kids
who would be less likely to hang out
with each other in the show notice how
Dustin is holding flowers now who do we
think those are for now judging from
this quick earlier shot of Max hitting
someone or something with this nail bat
I think these two guys are on their way
to see her so maybe Dustin is hanging
out with Steve trying to get advice on
how to be more of a Casanova DIY street
weapons of course ladies can't get
enough of them which two characters do
you think will form the most surprising
pairing this season and what do you
think would be the biggest threat facing
Hawkins in season 2 the government
whatever those small creatures are Billy
11 or that so Hydra Bard
I want to believe comment down below or
tweet me your thoughts Eddie gave us or
for all the new rock stars at new rock
stars for updates on your videos and
subscribe to this channel for all of our
deep dives and a stranger things and
other shows you love and if you wanna
help this channel grow you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially math you
solve us alright thanks for watching bye